bueno más que razones hablaríamos de
excusas porque lo que dicen es que lo
hacen para garantizar que la vuelta a
las escuelas de las niñas cumple con las
normas de esta interpretación tan
estricta de la ley islámica que tienen
ellos pero la realidad es que es un
golpe más a los derechos de las mujeres
y las niñas que llevan haciendo desde
hace siete meses es decir prohibir la
educación a las niñas es un elemento más
de estas normas restrictivas que han
venido a vulnerar todos los derechos de
todas las mujeres y de todas las niñas
en los últimos meses por tanto no sirven
excusas porque claramente lo que quieren
es seguir tratando a las mujeres ya las
niñas como ciudadanas de segunda que es
lo que llevan haciendo estos siete meses
y se ha criticado también duramente esta
cancelación que se tomaba además como
punto de negociación para la ayuda
internacional
repercutirá esta decisión en el posible
envío de ayuda humanitaria
pues habrá que ver desde luego lo que
hace falta es que haya una presión
internacional fuerte porque
probablemente no es esto no es solamente
responsabilidad de las autoridades
talibanas que desde luego lo es pero
también la comunidad internacional que
prometió garantizar y ayudar a que se
garantizará la igualdad entre mujeres y
niñas en afganistán tiene un papel que
hacer y aquí tienen que entrar políticos
tienen que entrar líderes mundiales
tienen que entrar organizaciones líderes
religiosos esto es un esfuerzo conjunto
el que hay que hacer para conseguir que
las niñas puedan volver a la escuela si
estamos viendo tan poco ahora como en
otras ocasiones como las mujeres afganas
y parte de la sociedad están desafiando
al régimen talibán y salen a
manifestarse ocurría también esto
durante el primer gobierno talibán o que
ha cambiado en estos últimos años
bueno claramente lo que demuestran estas
mujeres que salen a la calle es una
valentía
impresionante que es digna de admiración
y desde luego lo que vienen a reclamar
es que una sociedad sin la mitad de la
población que pueda ejercer todos sus
derechos sin su participación en la vida
pública y privada es una sociedad que
pierde y bueno se arriesgan a
probablemente a represarías y a
violencia como ya ocurrió en otras
manifestaciones que han hecho y desde
luego pues tienen que verlas tienen que
escuchar las lamentablemente hasta ahora
no no ha sido así y por eso es muy
importante no ellas mismas lo dicen que
no les olvidemos desde el exterior que
las acompañemos en su lucha porque desde
dentro son demasiadas las barreras que
tienen en todos los ámbitos de su vida y
es fundamental pues que también esta
solidaridad desde población y desde
activismo y desde sociedad civil desde
otros países estamos acompañando las
e insistiendo en su lucha y en defender
sus derechos humanos